14ème journée de mobilisation contre la
réforme des retraites à l'appel de
l'Inter syndical peu de perturbations
dans les transports mais 250 cortèges
prévus aujourd'hui évidemment que sur le
sujet purement des retraites c'est sans
doute une des dernières journées
mobilisation et j'ai envie de dire à
ceux qui nous écoutent raison de plus
pour y aller dans les 250 cortèges il y
a toujours autant de mobilisations cette
réforme ne doit pas s'appliquer elle n'a
aucune justification économique elle est
extrêmement violente socialement et
contrairement à ce que j'entends trop
souvent tout n'est pas plié c'est pas
vrai cette fois une mobilisation au plus
bas apparaît 31 000 manifestants selon
la préfecture 300 000 selon la CGT pour
ça que nous nous trouvons aujourd'hui
devant l'Assemblée nationale c'est pour
interpeller solennellement Yelle brune
pivel la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale c'est son rôle de laisser
voter les députés et le gouvernement
doit entendre le vote des députés
attention sur les questions de pouvoir
d'achat d'organisation du travail de de
dialogue social si vous voulez nous
présenter mesurer ça va pas passer donc
il a passé pas la fin de l'histoire il y
aura un mois de septembre il y aura un
mois d'octobre on verra bien ce qui se
passera pour info ça sera pas la
dernière en inter syndicale on va
décider de la suite de votre avis en
intercal ah mais votre avis c'est quoi
vous moi est-ce que j'ai l'air de
vouloir tourner la page il y aura
d'autres dates de mobilisation vous le
souhaitez on va regarder quelle forme de
mobilisation et quelle date de
mobilisation nous prenons le président
c'était engagé à 100 jours pour parvenir
à l'apaisement l'évidence c'est que
l'objectif ne sera pas atteint c'est
tout l'inverse il a un pays qui est plus
fracturé que jamais et puis à côté de
Paris ce sont des manifestants de la CGT
qui ont envahi le siège du Comité
olympique situé dans le 93 à
Aubervilliers aujourd'hui on vit une
démocrature mais c'est démocratures
peut demain ouvrir une dictature plus
loin c'est derrière des parapluies
noires que les manifestants radicaux se
protègent
puis c'est au tour des CRS de reculer
sous les hués qu'il ne croit pas que la
couleur dure je le dis ici tôt ou tard
l'heure viendra où cette réforme des
retraites sera abrogée ces blagues blocs
qui ont donc disposé des palettes en
plein milieu du boulevard les ont ils
ont allumé et font brûler actuellement
du mobilier urbain pour l'instant il n'y
a pas eu de monter en tension pas
d'affrontement avec les forces de
l'ordre que j'ai le sentiment
aujourd'hui que le pays c'est apaisé
est-ce que vous allez recevoir les
syndicats
un concert qui a été agressé au mode de
civilisations la polémique à votre
recadrage de la première ministre
non mais madame le vôtre aussi Dieu il
est fait vous mourrez et moi aussi alors
évidemment que si on y va comme ça
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse
non les jeux ne sont pas fait pardon je
blague mais la réforme des retraites a
été promulguée les décrets d'application
ont été mis en place le week-end dernier
non pas contre les Français mais bien
pour leur système de solidarité par
répartition nous devons pouvoir avancer
maintenant oui bah comme je vous disais
ça c'est une cabane de chantier
je pense que ça va accélérer
l'intervention des forces de l'ordre
après ces procédures que vous avez
cyniquement utilisé pour bâillonner le
Parlement une première sous la Cinquième
République vous avez ajouté à l'actrice
sociale une crise institutionnelle vous
deviez apaiser mais vous avez jeté de
l'île sur le feu on crée en quelque
sorte des bulles de savon et même plus
de mousse
et alors de ça il est hyper fier hyper
fier du coup de la bulle de savon
monsieur le président Bertrand pencher
vous le savez et monsieur le député de
Courson grand défenseur de la rue
rigueur budgétaire le sait aussi votre
proposition de loi est
inconstitutionnelle j'ai pas de ça fait
combien de temps vous n'avez pas touché
sa retraite bah janvier 2021 ça tombe
bien on est en jour de manifestation
aujourd'hui pour les retraites voilà et
MSA on balcon il veut sa retraite plus
rien ne retient les flots les os du
Nièvre s'engouffre à travers une brèche
géante du barrage de kakovka et se
déverse en aval selon les autorités
ukrainiennes les russes auraient fait
sauter le barrage depuis l'intérieur de
la salle des machines la nuit dernière
Kiev et Moscou s'accuse mutuellement
d'avoir causé cette catastrophe et de
chaque côté de la rive les évacuations
ont commencé